>> Kennedy: IF YOU ARE A WOMAN
WHO VOTED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP,
TURNS OUT YOU ARE TOO STUPID TO
MAKE YOUR OWN DECISIONS.
CONGRATULATIONS, LADIES.
THIS ACCORDING TO BARBRA
STREISAND.
SHE WAS SLAMMING FEMALE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS SAYING "A LOT OF
WOMEN VOTE THE WAY THEIR
HUSBANDS VOTE.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE ENOUGH IN
THEIR OWN THOUGHTS.
MAYBE THAT WOMAN WAS SO
ARTICULATE, SO EXPERIENCED IN SO
FIT FOR THE PRESIDENCY WAS TOO
INTIMIDATING.
OR SHE WAS ONE OF THE VERY WORST
CANDIDATES EVER SEEK THE HIGHEST
OFFICE IN THE LAND."
JESSE, ARE WOMEN TOO DUMB TO
THINK FOR THEMSELVES?
>> Jesse: WHAT A LAYUP.
HALF THE HUSBANDS I KNOW, THEY
ARE SO WAIVED, THEIR WIVES TELL
THEM WHO TO VOTE FOR.
I KNOW HUSBANDS WHO STAY AT
HOME.
THEIR WIVES MAKE MORE THAN THEY
DO.
I KNOW SO MANY HUSBANDS WHO DO
WHATEVER THEIR WIVES WANT.
I THINK SHE HAS A TOTALLY WRONG.
SHE IS STUCK IN A TIME WARP.
DEMOCRATS STILL CAN'T WRAP THEIR
HEAD AROUND THE FACT THAT WOMEN
DIDN'T VOTE FOR HILLARY BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T LIKE HILLARY.
THEY DIDN'T LOVE TRUMP BUT THEY
JUST REALLY DIDN'T LIKE HILLARY.
THEY ARE GENDER SHAMING TOWARDS
2020 AND SAYING WE ARE WATCHING
YOU, LADIES.
WE ARE WATCHING YOU.
>> Kennedy: THAT'S WHY A LOT
OF POWERFUL, SUCCESSFUL WOMEN
DON'T CONSIDER THEMSELVES
FEMINISTS BECAUSE THEY BECAME
POWERFUL AND SUCCESSFUL BY
BREAKING THE MOLD AND NOT GIVING
INTO GROUPTHINK.
THEY HAVE A NATURAL CURIOSITY
WHICH BARBRA STREISAND, WHO WAS
POWERFUL AND SUCCESSFUL, DOESN'T
SEEM TO UNDERSTAND WHICH MAKES
HER HYPOCRITE.
SHE ALSO SAID THAT SHE'S BEEN
HAVING CRAVINGS SINCE THE
PRESIDENT WAS ELECTED AND SHE
HAS BEEN INDULGING IN PANCAKES.
>> Dana: SPECIFICALLY BUT
QUITE PANCAKES.
BUTTER ON THEM AND MAPLE SYRUP
TO EASE THE PAIN.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME SHE
HAS SAID SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
GOING BACK FOR A FEW DECADES.
IF YOU ARE A REPUBLICAN WOMAN
AND YOU VOTE REPUBLICAN, THEN
SURELY SOMEONE IS CONTROLLING
YOUR BRAIN.
MUST BE YOUR HUSBAND BECAUSE YOU
ARE SO DEPENDENT ON HIM.
IT'S NOT TRUE IN MOST CASES OF
ANYONE I'VE EVER KNOWN,
INCLUDING THE FAMILY I GREW UP
IN IN WYOMING.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO ME.
DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING AT A MAJOR
GENDER GAP.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE LOOKING AT
REPUBLICANS AND SAYING WE HAVE
YOU NOW.
AND THEY MIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Kennedy: HAVE TO RUN THE
RIGHT CANDIDATE.
YOU KNOW BARBRA STREISAND.
>> Geraldo: I DO.
WE WERE NEIGHBORS FOR MANY YEAR
YEARS.
>> Kennedy: HAS SHE LOST HER
MIND?
>> Geraldo: MY WIFE SAID YOU
BETTER NOT DIS BARBRA.
THERE IS NO DOUBT BUT THAT FOR
WOMEN OF CHILDBEARING AGE, THERE
IS A LOATHING FOR THE 45TH
PRESIDENT THAT KNOWS NO BOUNDS
RADIO THING I CAN POSSIBLY
COMPARE IT TO IS HOW PEOPLE FELT
ABOUT RICHARD NIXON IN THE
HEIGHT OF WATERGATE.
THEY HATE PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
SO FAR AS WOMEN UNION LOCKSTEP
WITH THEIR HUSBANDS, THOSE WHO
VOTED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND
MY FAMILY, THE WOMEN MAKE THE
DECISIONS.
I SWEAR TO GOD MY WIFE ERICA
SENT MY THEN 11-YEAR-OLD
DAUGHTER INTO THE VOTING BOOTH
WITH ME TO MAKE SURE I DID NOT
VOTE FOR MY DEAR FRIEND,
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Kennedy: GREG, LET ME ASK
YOU THIS.
WE ARE FACING A CROSSROADS.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A GENDER
WAR.
WHERE DO WE GO FROM HERE?
DO WE ELECT BARBRA STREISAND
PRESIDENT IN 2020.
>> Greg: EITHER HER OR BETTE
MIDLER.
I CAN'T TELL THE DIFFERENCE.
THE WORST SEXISTS AGAINST WOMEN
ARE WOMEN.
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH ME, IT'S
BECAUSE HE WEAK WOMAN CONTROLLED
BY YOUR MAN.
PERHAPS THE MOST THING YOU CAN
SAY, AND IT'S COMING FROM
ANOTHER WOMAN.
I WOULD VENTURE TO SAY
CONSERVATIVE AND LIBERTARIAN
MEN, HOLD WOMEN IN HIGHER
RESPECT THAN ANY LIBERAL
INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE WE DON'T SEE
YOU AS A POLITICAL PAWN.
WE ACTUALLY SEE YOU AS A PERSON
WITH A BRAIN.
TO JESSE'S POINT, WOULD HAPPILY
HAND OVER POWER.
TO STILL BELIEVE IN THIS
PATRIARCHAL B.S. THAT MEN ARE
WALKING AROUND, LIKE WHERE HAVE
YOU BEEN?
>> Jesse: IF THERE IS A GENDER
WAR, WE SURRENDER.
YOU GUYS CAN TAKE IT.